hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alva I'm John Humphrey and with
us is cut - what's up guys Omni here
Omni not Omni one media media Michael B
you've probably heard her shout him out
several times one of our top patrons
over at patreon is on YouTube channel
I pledged his channel on our community
page before because he's great at what
he does reactions reviews a lot of
insight a lot of commentary and he had
this video request that I was like you
know what I've seen enough for your
videos why don't you just collab with
him make the video yourself yeah so his
video we want to just tell them what the
request was Michael yeah um with the
Joker movie coming out later this year
how did kind of taking that what is it
how did you say that Joker movie he's a
[Music]
jukebox movie coming out this fall kind
of taking a realistic psychological
approach on a classic villain that we
all kind of know in one way taking a
different angle and spin on it I posed
the question to you guys what other
fictional villain would you like get the
same kind of psychological grounded
treatment man we should put some thought
into this video
I feel like Michael probably really
mapped his [ __ ] out you've got like one
of those boards with the red straight
backs and like clippings like a whole
outline yeah I made this decision
yesterday yeah so guys make sure to go
to Michael's channel seriously it's
great there's a reason I've taken the
liberty to plug it several several times
yeah I I mean I got a few I figured it'd
be fun if we kind of just you know talk
the [ __ ] or where the people say it took
us an hour to figure out a way to do
this so by the time we figured it out we
became brain for
and here we go settled on an inefficient
way to do it it's like all right it
works whatever work let's hope this
works or else you just got a waste of
footage here so it's gonna work guys
it's not hope let's know yes I believe
okay
I'll kick this off yeah being going in
theme with DC and the Batman universe I
feel like what a lot of people probably
jump to you know outside of the DC
universe you'll hear a lot of people say
like Doctor Doom and whatever and I say
nay I have one that could be really
grounded really cool it was one of the
earliest Batman villains I ever became
gravitated towards and fortunately he
made an appearance in Batman Begins and
that is Jonathan crane as the Scarecrow
is when my choices the orange I did you
choose we know I first saw I first saw
this maybe mean crossover so well what
weren't you number did you come up what
origin are you drawn to you know know
you you wanted to start this off go
right ahead buddy I was drawn there's
there's several different iterations of
Jonathan crane and the one that I the
first one I read which I think is how he
was introduced I remember being in the
North Hollywood Public Library has
flipping through a bunch of graphic
novels and this one was when he was a
professor at school and he was teaching
on about fear and he brought a gun to
the class and he fired like something
about getting a reaction out of students
and he got fired for that and he wanted
to get revenge on his professors in
everyone at the school so he became a
thief but I feel like you can go
obviously deeper than that and really
explore the elements of fear sometimes
when you make an anti hero or a villain
a main character it can limit that fear
capacity but with the Scarecrow serum or
not the serum the gas or whatever the
hell they feel toxins that really allows
itself of some crazy visuals II Michael
you watch Gotham I forget yes well I I
really like when the Scarecrow shows up
and there be
as you get a lot of crazy ass like just
straight-up creepypasta kind of horror
visuals and I think that's one thing I
would really love to see I think we
could have even got like a Ryan Murphy
to direct it or something like that
thing is like you have so much sinister
backstory with the Scarecrow too because
even like the childhood of the Scarecrow
is like really messed up like the way
like he grew up with this like super
draconian like religious upbringing
where they would like lock him in this
like stone shed as punishments and stuff
like that and like really torment the
child that was Jonathan crane yeah you
know what we actually kills his family
you really get to see why he's obsessed
with fear and it's like usually some
expositional villainous cliche line but
yeah it would be cool to really explore
like really underline that word
why why why he is so why he believes in
fear so much and the struggle within him
over fear and and everything that comes
with it that eventually consumes him and
leads him to becoming yeah immersing
himself and then taking it as his weapon
and as his symbol you know yeah don't
talk I know I don't want it no no
Michael I uh brought you here so a
little tweak to that origin like I
wasn't in the same version that you were
talking about I do recall that he kind
of like they they ran a farm that was
where he kind of got the symbolism of
the Scarecrow but I wanted to do when I
was thinking about I was like how can we
dive a little deeper into this and I
kind of like melded some ideas from
another movie that did this not so good
and that would be Rob Zombie's Michael
Myers film the Halloween movie not so
good no go no you want to go hey I like
that movie I just think that part of
that that part of the story kind of took
a backseat if you ask me you're making
things very awkward Michael
uh I'm sorry anyway think about a kid
that drive in this kind of setting or I
don't mean to throw you off your pitch
my but we appreciate you never gonna be
an actor if you can't sincerely
apologize or a youtuber apparently oh no
you don't have to sincerely apologize
for anything it's just the words right
but like the he grows up in that setting
you know slightly abusive family but if
you kind of go only a little only a
little but if you go into the aspect of
phobia you go with the kid that
naturally just has a fear of practically
everything there I can't remember the
name pantophobia the ones like all of it
yeah
and just that becoming like a thorn in
his life to the point where in his
formative years may be bullied outside
of the home stuff like that much like
young Michael Myers was and then the the
mask or the persona becomes a defense
mechanism at after a point he
dissociates from the Jonathan crane and
creates this protective persona to kind
of shelter the child kind of like if you
watched Iron Fist season 2 except also
probably better executed which character
was an iron fist
the was her name the the assassin that
was hunting him oh yeah yeah yeah but
yeah just kind of like see that kind of
degrade and then it becomes this
protective force in the way that Batman
end up ends up using his fear of bats as
kind of his own weapon I but we would
see kind of like it come out of a form
of self-defense to shelter and protect
his mind maybe they're not even like in
cahoots kind of like
they maybe switch personalities like
that same character in certain
situations yeah exactly and maybe
something like that
rather than just uh it was a freed as a
kid and bullied so I'm now I'm going to
just even murder everybody that would
actually work well along the line it's I
think the way we all worked this one
pitch was great I think this is how the
writers room for terminator dark fate
went I have a general idea you elaborate
more and then he solidifies this is the
dream team right now I just start making
pitch I rolled the dough yeah you put
the cheese and the sauce on and he bakes
the whole final draft I've always
thought it because it's a suicide note
I've always thought it'd be cool to do
kind of a villain mashup movie where
like you know you know those like Batman
stories were made this was like a lot of
comic book characters - we're all like
the row gallery come together to fight
Batman but there's still the villains
like that's how those comics work in
Batman still the hero I always thought
it'd be cool to do one where you you get
kind of these like soullow origin movies
of these characters and then when they
team up that you you capture the focus
point from the villains and you never
see Bruce Wayne you you see them you see
the villains and how they view Batman
and Batman's ascent write it as the
villain in that movie yeah yeah these
free Batman is he's the bad guy in the
movie I feel like that'd be a unique
that would be that would be interesting
and like if taking this same concept
we've kind of you know writers room
together here that could be something
that comes up towards the tail end maybe
he's finally growing this personas
helping him overcome his fear and then
the Batman
[Music]
and in the final after credits scene you
see him counseling Thomas Eliot and we
can set up a hush for sequel sit part 2
mmm yes
did you see the that's the next DC
animated film I read the comic so many
years ago I barely remember that any of
it and I have hushed many times in my
life yeah I usually tell him the hush
once a day but I don't know a separate
note I like completely separate note I
also thought like some other villains
that I would like to see origins too and
I feel like this might be a bit of a
cliche choice but I get the impression
Marvel themselves is very interested in
exploring kingpins origins you when you
look at daredevil like you really get
into the backstory a lot of kingpin and
and even even an unexpired man into the
spider verse you get some real personal
identity for kingpin but one thing that
the movie that daredevil show or a
daredevil movie - or even spider-verse
they don't show you
it's truly his rise to being kingpin you
don't get that you in like daredevil
season one you see his backstory what
made him the monster within that he is
but it would be cool I think it'd be
really neat to see that and I don't know
exactly when Vanessa in terms of
comic-book Laura when Vanessa comes into
the to the kingpin storyline but I know
in the in the comics Vanessa's but like
they're kind of like you know king and
queen together and I think daredevil
season 3 really started ending at that
potentially happening but of course it
doesn't come into full fruition I think
it'd be neat if you kind of toyed with
some of that lineage really see the rise
of kingpin not to see his childhood but
see the what made him kingpin but also
have the love story the dark twisted
love story between him and Vanessa and
they kind of rule as king and queen by
the end and then daredevil shows up at
the end it kicks
[Laughter]
that's the end of every one of these
pitches yeah except for like when we
really threw the audience a curveball
and put it at the beginning and then cut
to five years earlier you guys you do
have that instance in a lot of these
storylines where the hero you know
unknowingly creates as villain so I mean
that could be the be rightly colored
costume or a darkly colored costume came
up and kicked me just out of nowhere I
was just walking down the street that's
a cool idea I like the UH the daredevil
kicks immunity I mean do you guys have
like other villains that yeah oh I do
you yeah I had a backup just in case the
Jonathan crane happened to be unanimous
it's so funny because you messaged me
saying do we want to share our thoughts
in case we have any overlap lend itself
to a grounded villain introduction
character makes the most sense I feel
like even more so than the rest of the
gallery really yeah no totally I got one
of my sleeve that could work but it's a
long shot but but you go first you go
first I want to hear this okay
my backup was well it it kind of bends
that rule of realism but when I mean
realism just really the the real way in
which the psychology is in put into play
or question and I feel like with the
Star Wars prequels we didn't really feel
that now I'm not saying rewrite the
prequels not by any means we've already
seen that story
why retread it right but what we didn't
see or what most people don't see in the
beginning what what was Anakin's life
like as a slave child
we don't wrestle like this what is your
end he breaks out and becomes my class
why GaN Jin shows up we're going
straight forward to some movies people
don't like very much
qui-gon did as when he stopped being a
slave afterwards and we quite gotten to
helped by his like gamble his way out of
slavery he would still need all that
episode1 stuff to complete the art from
a slave to non slave no you know it just
ends with that cuz just like with rogue
one it just ends with the beginning of a
new hope but the characters jerk the
main characters journeys and though is
part way into that that is true I guess
like like Jenner says journey ends and
every every one of the characters they
tidy they're all across town in the
galaxy show you the Darth Vader T's and
Leia T's and all that but they don't it
could be it could be the race in which
he lost his his last speeder the whole
like build-up to the hell I didn't think
I wanted to see a movie about the plans
for the dead are so maybe you're right
yeah the story of how Anakin very nearly
got out of slavery but leave me wanting
more because that's how movies are good
well the thing is like the thing that
always kind of like bothered me about
Episode one is like you you meet him
he's he's in this slave he's he's living
this slave life and he's running around
yee-haa like nothing's the problem but
then like later he's like I grew up a
slave it was awful and I was he like had
a what seemed like the dream job for him
but then he always like reflects on it
like it was this awful thing but we
never really got that impression but
obviously it's supposed to have informed
on his character later in life I want
ever really like weighed in on it well
they cut out an hour of beating sequence
yeah
a little boy 12 years old asleep again -
good then it ends with him being saved
by the white magical I didn't realize we
could pull from other other fandoms yeah
well hey I'm the knight it sounds like
we might be getting the literacy an
Oscar show about that guy get stabbed
what and ultimately just like wiped out
it really rust chain of events the thing
I realized about the night king is I
don't want to know more about who he is
or what he no thanks I just wanted him
to have more impact that would last
beyond like up that's fixed but anyway I
the night arguing do you still have
slave stuff or can I go go right a slave
cinema go ahead III will not interject
okay mine is a little left of center but
the more I thought about it stick with
me cuz I think it could be a cool off
the beaten path a villain movie in the
style of Joker but with a different
genre fusion going on I have long had a
a fixation an affinity for the DC
villains solomon grundy and i thought
this could be neat because the story of
solomon grundy warps a lot over time
especially across multiple books and so
you could have him start as this lowlife
thug and you know he gets killed he gets
dropped in you know murder swamp or
whatever is called and a slaughter swamp
is that it yeah slaughter swamp there we
go and you know he's resurrected from
there but in the old fashion of zombies
you know where he's kind of a mindless
creature but over time and over r-e
generations the thing is every time he
gets killed he rises again from the
swamp which is you know a pretty
mumbo-jumbo ii thing but each time he
comes back he's a little bit different
and he picks up character and intellect
over time and eventually becomes
something of an antihero so in his
earlier in mid stages as a villain he
winds up with a
other DC and Batman centric villains and
has often made their pond but eventually
he wises up to that and wants to leave
that life and does at least arguably out
of happenstance wind up doing some
heroic things and helping the heroes at
time so I thought what you could do is
make a supervillain origin movie that
has you know a certain level of like
lowlife crime involved that's a very
familiar place to exist for these things
it kind of reminded me of like you know
that Joker comic book they released
after the Dark Knight where it's like
from the perspective of a different guy
in the gang I thought you could kind of
take that idea and fuse it with a
Frankenstein sort of story because
solomon grundy is a character that you
can at first yeah he's gonna start out
kind of lifeless once he first
resurrects but you could play a really
sad and a really touching kind of
character growth out of that I think if
you had you know enough time and
elements to play with you know you could
get your crime you could get a Batman
and Robin cameo in there because they've
had run-ins with him you could get other
villains and you could also have him
rise from being a criminal to being a
mindless zombie to being actually a
person who wants to have some kind of
life you know so uh I don't know I've
always been enamored by that character
and so I thought as a villain origin
that could be kind of cool well I think
yeah flash it out a little more I think
I mean you might have an idea like that
one I think he's got a six movie arc
right there Cyrus gold let's do it I
want six movies but here's the thing
you couldn't proach it that way too you
could do a straight-up like you could
every movie he could be completely
different
don't don't change him over one movie
just change them from movie to movie and
you could have six solomon grundy movies
and that will still not tire people out
you could even stretch it to seven
movies and then split glass you know
born up the first one born on a Monday
and just go through the whole week dude
Oh
seething you're the you're the oven man
you're the bait of it yeah I got the the
shape we got the baked and you are the
guy who puts the little spritz of love
on top it's the salt meme guy yeah I'm
like I'm like the Involvement James
Cameron had terminator Kirk
yeah the thing that gets everyone
excited of the wiping in this motor goes
sounds good and you're selling all the
tickets
besides Linda Hamilton who's gonna start
as Solomon grazie
either that mean it it does seem to be a
trend uh you know swap up character
genders races and stuff like that was
envisioned to be alive black gay
disabled old everything I think I think
what the MCU should do and I pitched
this out one or kombu V fights they
should do a movie about the Mandarin
it's good like the real Mandarin the one
marble one shot T's that we never got
that Kevin Feige every three to five
years like no no we're gonna do it he's
still up still he's still out there
because I'm Anderson I mean we killed
off Tony Stark appearance now that Iron
Man's all the way let's get his nemesis
in there right I thought an Ursula movie
could be cool I mean Mandarin has a
crazy backstory with that he does would
like that yes he does being like a
warlord obtaining the ten rings he has
multiple different backgrounds some
liver is like orphaned and then raised
by like rich aunts rich like aunt or
something and then banished from it but
either way he liked the power of the ten
rings and becoming a warlord I think
that'd be really cool and I always
thought I also thought I'd be like
interesting to toy with the title of the
Mandarin cuz it's over time and
perceived as a rather racist title
obviously right and he really just likes
those orange you can't choose your
nicknames man you just gotta eat one
food all the time what do you expect
it's actually just about him in a class
learning meter yeah you like guys
learning Mandarin right I recall you
Mandarin they say China's on the rise in
the global marketplace but to have it be
like to have it be like a nickname that
other people called him you know and
then that he didn't bestow upon himself
but you know he sort of embraced like
every other MCU character who never uses
the road exactly
but but he can say that like he knew he
could even acknowledge it it's kind of
racist actually but
name that people have come to fear if
you acknowledge that people can't
criticize it yeah it's true that's how
you do it you just exploiting it out
yeah because you pointed it out it's not
a problem anymore
well anyway and I mean I think we should
we're at this we're going on we're going
on like 30 we're going on 45 minutes
here I don't have any other notes I
don't think man that's an hour and 45
minutes if one food the whole runtime I
want some people to watch this video
yeah if your villi still I didn't flesh
out nurse'll a movie but I don't think
an Ursula movie could be pretty cool
that's all I got today
I think they should read it should make
another attempt at a Catwoman movie
because he got like Tim Burton's origins
which is like Tim Burton's or second I
thought you meant a movie about yeah and
then you got that terrible Halle Berry
one that the Catwoman origin that I was
drawn to was the one from Batman year
one where she where they slightly
borrowed Dark Knight Rises slightly
borrowed from it but they swapped out a
black girl with Anne Hathaway yeah and
but you know having that really just
poverty driven life and I think and
you're one she's she a prostitute or
something like that I don't think she
was but she had this little like
sidekick that I think was yeah not
really sidekick but like her little
little friend look now fired that price
yeah yeah foggy Nelson yeah I think
something like that would be really cool
to see you get a you know the [ __ ]
Lupita Nyong'o to play yeah
anywho yeah well this was fun hey man
that's how gold is made alright guys
well make sure to pitch your villains
down in the comment boxes and which ones
you'd want to see I know everyone wants
a dr. doom movie don't worry they're
working on it Michael thanks so much for
being here dude yeah man thank you guys
for allowing this to happen even though
it was the biggest chore to make
worthy before we filmed I was like I
don't know if I want to film anymore
this is coming a lot of fun filming is a
lot of fun to film and if this works out
we know how to do it like right next
time so Omni media go check out his
channel this guy has a lot of great
reactions a lot of great reviews
obviously a lot of it's very insightful
commentary so please go check out his
channel you can subscribe to us click
the notification bell hit that like
button we'll catch you guys soon
peace
you